- I think that from a very young age,
watching anime and seeing
those depictions of friendship,
like I didn't have like a
lot of friends growing up
and I don't have a huge
amount of friends now,
but the intensity with
which I love my friends,
the amount of time, and effort,
and energy I put into my friendships,
I think has been like
directly fed to me from anime.
I feel like anime taught me
you don't need to have a lot of friends,
you just need to have the
people that understand you,
that love you at both your best and worst,
that would take a bullet for you
and that you would take a bullet for.
And that's how I feel about my friends.
Like we cannot talk for three months,
and if they called me and they're like,
hey look, I got a body I need to bury,
I'd be like, bet, say less.
(bright music)
- You are listening to the
"MANA Podcast" from Netflix.
I'm your host, Matt Owens.
I'm a screenwriter, co-show runner
on the upcoming live action
adaptation of "One Piece"
from Netflix, and most
importantly, a lifelong anime fan.
The "MANA Podcast" stands for
Manga, Anime, Netflix Adaptation,
and it's an opportunity
for us to talk about
our love of all things manga and anime.
I've invited some of my
closest friends to chat.
We're gonna keep this fun and casual,
and we're really glad that
you've decided to join us.
This is the "MANA Podcast."
Oh, and also there will be spoilers,
so check the podcast
description for that list.
(bright upbeat music)
Joining me on the MANA Podcast today,
you know her, you love her,
from "Reign" to "Grey's Anatomy,"
my friend, Adelaide Kane.
- Hi, buddy, how you doin'?
- I'm doing well.
Why don't you introduce
yourself a little bit
to our audience.
- I'm Adelaide Kane.
You might know me from such
projects as "Teen Wolf",
"Reign", "Grey's Anatomy",
"Once Upon a Time,"
and you know that one movie
where people killed each other a bunch?
There's several of those movies actually,
had a long history in B-grade horror
before my career took off.
I've been a long-time actor
and a longer time anime fan
since I was like a kid.
I remember in like my early tween years
sneaking into the living
room with my little brother
to turn on "Adult Swim" on Cartoon Network
to watch like "Trigun" and "Cowboy Bebop."
'Cause that's what Adult Swim
was back when I was a teenager
in like the early 2000s.
It was the only way that we
could watch anime back then.
And in my hometown a volume of manga
was like $20 'cause it was all imported.
So I got a job very
young so I could afford
to buy volumes of manga
that I would read in 15 minutes,
and then I'd have to wait
a month for the next volume
to come into the one store
in Perth that sold Manga.
So those are my credentials,
and yeah, that's why I'm here, you know,
chop it up about some
of my favorite shows.
- So what would you say your favorite is?
What is the one anime or manga for you?
- Hmm, it's really
difficult to just pick one,
because I have like the old
school anime that I started on
that always has a special
place in my heart,
and then like the newest stuff,
there's some really cool like new stuff
that's been coming out lately like,
"So I'm a Spider, So What?"
I really loved "Kotaro Lives Alone",
like "Spy x Family" I'm obsessed with.
I really love "Hunter X Hunter,"
and I know it's like huh,
everybody loves "Hunter X Hunter."
Well I do, okay?
I do, I don't wanna hear
about it from anime purists.
- "Yu Yu Hakusho's" better.
- Oh my god, are we gonna
get into a debate about this
on the podcast?
- It's the hill
that I'm gonna die on.
- Okay, well you will die alone. (laughs)
So I don't know, I
couldn't pick a favorite.
I think the one that really
stuck with me when I was a kid,
so much so that I named my cat
after the title character is "Ranma 1/2."
And that's like a old-school
sort of episodic style,
gender bending martial arts
anime from like the '90s.
And not a lot of people
understand that reference.
I'm like, "Yeah, my cat's name is Ranma,
and they're like, "Ramna, Ramdan?"
And I'm like, "Ramna."
And not a lot of people get
that that's what I've named him
after that was sort of like, you know,
the beginning of the end for me.
And I've been watching
anime ever since. Yeah.
So if I had to pick a favorite,
I guess I'd pick that one.
- That's a great one.
I remember going to Barnes
and Noble back in the day
and just, you would only look
at whatever was available
and it was a really limited selection,
but Ramna was one of them.
It was like right up there
right next to like "Inuyasha"
and a bunch of early classic-
- Yeah,
it's like in that pocket,
like during that time.
And I remember very
distinctly it was, you know,
before they figured out
that they needed to put
age restrictions on manga,
it was one of the few manga
that like had boobs in it. (laughs)
- Yep.
- And now they have age
restrictions on stuff.
But oh my god, walking
into Barnes and Noble
into the manga section, it was wild.
It was wild out there up until sort of,
I think like 2010 when they figured out
there was some really adult
content in some of that manga.
Like, I read stuff like
online and in manga
that I was much too young to be reading
'cause they did not
cotton on to the content
until I guess it became more popular.
And it's just so nuts because
now anime and manga is cool,
and popular, and it's a direct correlation
between the K-pop stands
and K-pop becoming such a huge thing.
And then like sort of by
default manga and anime,
and that kind of culture
has now also become cool and mainstream.
And I'm like, when was this?
When I was in high school
I was mocked relentlessly
for liking anime and manga.
People thought I was a little creep.
And to be fair I was. (laughs)
But you know, it's so funny
'cause that stigma of being an anime fan
from when I was in high school, it's like,
it's cool now and I'm like,
where was this when I,
I could have been cool,
I could've been cool.
And it's really great.
It's so fun just like
watching all these kids
wander around in their
"One Piece" t-shirts
and they're like, you know
"Dragon Ball" t-shirts and stuff,
and I'm like, you don't even know,
you don't even know what
the struggle was like.
- What we had to go through.
- What we had to go through! (groans)
- But that's also, I mean,
I think that's how growing
up being interested
in this stuff, that's
how we found our friends.
That's how we found our groups.
Who are the other people
that are being bullied
for wearing Hot Topic
"Dragon Ball" t-shirts and,
- Yeah.
- going home early to watch
"Sailor Moon" episodes.
- Yeah, I mean Australia's
like a very athletic culture
and country, and even just
being really into reading books.
So like my little nerd
group in high school,
we all had like very
specific special interests.
I didn't really have a lot of friends
that was super into
sort of anime and manga,
the friends that I did have
were like in the boarding school
and they were all from like
Malaysia and Indonesia,
and they would give me
these computer CD ROMs
full of manga.
And I got banned from using the computer
because I wouldn't do any of my work,
I would just like read
volumes, and volumes,
and volumes, and volumes of manga
in like these massive like
four inch tall CD sleeves
of manga disks that my
friends would give me.
It's so funny now,
especially with the internet,
it's like even if you're in a small town
where nobody likes the things you like,
you can have a whole community online.
And I think with the
popularization of anime,
and like, animation in general,
especially like adult animation,
combined with the
availability of streaming,
the community's just much, much bigger
and there's a lot more available.
Like you don't have to
go on sketchy websites
like "Manga Cat" to read your manga.
- Manga Cat.
- There's now whole dedicated
sections in the bookstore,
and it's really easily accessible online,
and you can sign up for
"Mad Comics," whatever,
or "Shonen Jump" and read in real time
as things come out.
You don't have to wait months,
and months, and months.
It's awesome. There's just
so much out there as well.
And we only, like here in
the English speaking world,
on like Netflix or other
streaming platforms,
we only have a microcosm of
the content that's available
that has been either dubbed into English
or subbed into English.
So it's really fantastic.
Like you could just spend all
day at home watching anime
and not having a life,
which I definitely don't
do at all. (laughs)
- And you're right, the
creation of those friendships,
those communities, that
is one of the best things
about manga and anime.
And that kind of brings us to the theme
that I wanna talk to
you about today, Addie.
- Nakama, the power of friendship.
- The power of friendship.
(Adelaide laughs)
It's something that is very important.
That term is really closely
tied to "One Piece,"
and it's used in a way, it
describes friendship and family,
but at a level that
goes beyond those terms.
It's the people that it doesn't matter
if you are related to them or not,
but it's your ride or die.
It's the people that you
would do anything for.
And the concept is something
that really permeates
a lot of series.
You know, people we do,
we joke about the power
of friendship, but it's-
- Yeah, 'cause it's cheesy, but it's true.
- It is, it's true.
And from "One Piece" to "Seven
Deadly Sins" to "Fairy Tail,'
it's like that bond,
that connection truly is
one of the greatest powers
and the greatest emotions that exist.
So like what is, when you
talk about the idea of nakama,
and like the power of friendship,
what does that mean to you?
- I think that from a very young age,
watching anime and seeing, you know,
those depictions of friendship,
like I didn't have a lot
of friends growing up,
and I don't have a huge
amount of friends now,
but the intensity with
which I love my friends,
and the amount of time,
and effort, and energy
I put into my friendships,
I think has been like
directly fed to me from anime.
I feel like anime taught me
you don't need to have a lot of friends,
you just need to have the
people that understand you,
that love you at both your best and worst,
that would take a bullet for you,
and that you would take a bullet for.
And that's how I feel about my friends.
Like we cannot talk for three months,
and if they called me and
they're like, hey look,
I got a body I need to bury,
I'd be like, bet, say less.
And we show up with a shovel, you know?
I think that it's also like
a really important lesson,
especially as you grow up, you know,
as all of us grow up and
we leave home and you know,
we start our own lives, your
friends do become your family.
They become your connection
to the outside world.
They become your connection to
your heart and your emotion.
I would say even more so
than romantic relationships.
Like I invest a lot of time
and effort in my friends
because in my mind they're
gonna be there forever.
You know, like those
are gonna be my people
for the rest of my life.
And I think it's really cool
that anime sort of sets you up
for that in a weird way.
Your friendships, like
finding the right people,
finding people who understand
you and who you understand
is so important in adulthood.
And as you go through life, you know,
'cause you leave your parents'
house and your siblings
and you all start your own lives,
and just maintaining that
connection with other human beings
and finding people who might
just sort of understand you
better or teach you new
things about yourself,
or about the world,
is like a really integral
part of growing up.
Whether you do that in real life,
whether you have that in
your online community,
and the amount of support
that you can find online
and through special interests
is really not to be
discounted in a world like,
especially post-pandemic
where all of our social skills
have gotten extraordinarily rusty,
those of us who had any to begin with.
And since we're anime stans,
that's really up for debate.
But yeah, it's a fantastic
thing to sort of instill
in kids and young people is
that friendship is important.
And not only that,
but friendship through good times and bad.
I think in a world where
we can feel more and more
disconnected from our
fellow man and the world,
it's a really beautiful part
of what makes anime anime.
And I think for a lot of us,
I can only speak for myself,
but for a lot of us that
were like anime fans
at a time when anime wasn't cool,
that idea or that fantasy of friendship
was so important to me.
Like that was something
I saw and I wanted,
I wanted it so badly.
And I worked really hard to
find people to have as family,
especially moving across
the planet when I was 19,
quite literally the other side
of the planet to Los Angeles,
I was like, I need friends.
I want that. I want those people.
I'm across the world from
everyone and everything
I've ever known, and the
only way I'll feel at home
in this strange land that is
the United States of America
is if I find my people.
- One of the things that you brought up
that I think is really
interesting is, you know,
a lot of main characters in anime series,
especially in the Shonen
genre, suffer from, you know,
dead parent syndrome.
They don't really have
families to speak of.
- Ugh, god no!
So it's that found family
- Exactly.
- trope is so important.
And you know, I think that that is like,
anime does hammer home the
importance of community,
which I think some of us forget about,
like how important that
is to have community.
I hate the dead parents
thing 'cause I'm like,
couldn't you just,
or it's like a single parent
or like an abusive parent.
Like even, in everything,
there's always dead parents.
- There's always some, at
least one person who is dead.
But that it goes to show that
like you can have these really
unconventional or sad
familial lives or upbringings,
but finding your people is possible
and that connection can be-
- Yeah, there's someone out there,
there's someone out there who
will be that family for you.
And what that means-
- And what's also nice,
it shows you, it's not always perfect
'cause no family is, no friendship is,
no relationship is.
'Cause you look at people
like Naruto and Sasuke,
who are best friends
but have literally
tried to kill each other
at multiple times throughout their lives.
- Oh yeah, no, totally.
- Or look at Zorro and Sanji,
dudes hate each other.
- Oh my god,
beat the shit out of each
each other on a regular basis.
- But they have each other's backs.
- Exactly.
- There's a wonderful
moment in the Wano arc
of the manga recently where
Sanji's really dealing with
the fact that he might
be becoming the monster
that his father tried to turn him into.
And he tells Zoro, "Hey man,
if things go sideways for me,
I need you to kill me."
And that just shows such a
trust between the two of them.
These guys were always
at each other's throats.
- It's like a profound act of trust.
- Yeah.
- And vulnerability.
- And it takes a real friend
to be able to do something.
Like, you're closest friends
- To be able to even have
- are the ones that are like-
- that conversation,
and like ask that, and not only that,
but like the level of
dedication and connection
to respond to that request
with, I've got you.
Because like, even as painful
as that would be for me,
it would be more painful for me to,
to see you become the thing
that you fear the most.
- And you know,
that's one of the great things
about our real relationships
and friendships is a
good friend is someone
who will support you and
prop you up and things,
but is also someone that's gonna be like,
hey man, cut it out.
- Go to therapy, figure
it out, stop it, stop!
I've had my friends do
that to me and I apologize,
and I'm like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You're right, you're right.
- You right, you're right,
you're right, you're right.
- Alright, so Naruto and
Sasuke, Zoro and Sanji,
those are some pretty good examples.
What are some other examples
of this idea of nakama
that like really resonate with you?
- Hmm, you know what really
just punched me so aggressively
in the feels?
"Kotaro Lives Alone."
I'm not a watering pot,
I like don't cry ever,
which is an ongoing
conversation with my therapist,
but "Kotaro Lives Alone" is just, huh!
Oh it hurts so much,
like this poor little
boy just living alone.
And as it unfolds, I
don't wanna spoil stuff,
but like, whatever, if you
haven't watched it yet,
what are you doing with your life?
You know, he moves into this building
and all of these kooky,
odd, eccentric people
who are also living in the building
just like take it upon themselves
to become his new family,
and to take care of him,
and love him, and look out for him,
and teach him the things
that he needs to know.
And it's just, it's so beautiful.
I think like anyone
with abandonment issues
would watch that and be like,
ah, it's just so gorgeous.
And I think what I really
love about anime is how,
for the most part, as flawed
as most characters are,
most of them also have like
redeeming qualities about them.
So like, even though you
have these like zany,
weird characters that
are almost like losers
in the world of the anime,
their inherent goodness,
and kindness, and caring
when there is this child in their life
that just needs help, and support,
and love, and guidance is
like, it was really beautiful.
And then on the other hand,
you have stuff like Killua and
Gon from "Hunter X Hunter."
- I knew you were coming here.
- of course we were because I love Killua,
- All right, state your case.
- so much!
I love Killua so much!
And he's just like such
a prickly, resentful,
standoffish little dude
and then going just sort of like,
blasts into his life with like his sunny,
almost psychotic levels of
like optimism and drive.
Gon is terrifying.
And that he's almost
conscienceless and that he's like
just so interested in
everything all the time,
regardless of whether morally
or ethically it's good or bad.
And he has his very own
strict moral compass
that he follows.
And as he continues to
power up through the series,
I'm like, you could be
either a god or a demon.
And killua's just like, oh Jesus, okay,
whatever you need bud.
And it's just is always there,
just like against his will,
just loves his friend so much
and would do anything for him.
Like to the point where he even overcame
Illumi's mind control stuff.
And I think that that really is like
a true representation of
the power of friendship,
that like, through friendship
and through healing,
through this friendship, you
know, he's become a stronger,
better version of himself,
a more kind, softer,
empathetic version of himself.
It's that old sort of villain
hero trope where it's like,
if you're alone then like
you can never be heard,
and people don't let you
down and blah, blah blah.
And it's like, no, actually,
through like the power
of love and friendship,
you can become a stronger,
better version of yourself.
And that's how I feel about
"Hunter X Hunter," so.
- Well-
- Do you have a rebuttal?
Am I wrong?
- I do have a rebuttal.
Here's why you say-
- Is this gonna be
the "Black Clover"
conversation all over again?
- I don't know them.
(Adelaide laughs)
Here's why Yusuke and
Kuwabara are a better example
of this ideal because-
- All right, team.
- You have, no, just wait. You'll see.
- I don't disagree, I'm
just being contrary,
let's continue.
- You have to,
see, this is our nakama
dynamic right here.
You have these two young men,
these two 14-year-old kids
who they hate one another,
but it's birthed out of a mutual respect
that neither of them understand
how to actually put into words.
And that kind of a bond
makes both of them grow,
not just as individuals,
they have to grow up,
and their rivalry that turns
into understanding and respect
not only helps them grow as fighters,
but it helps 'em grow as young men,
learning that that kind
of toxic masculinity,
that rivalry that they have,
that's not how you have to
interact with another young man.
And so there's so much
personal and paired growth
to the two of them over
the course of that.
'Cause you look at those early episodes
and they're just wanting to
fight each other in the street
all the time.
And then as you continue
moving through the series,
these two have each other's
backs at every point.
And I think there's a lot
of really great lessons
to be learned from that.
And also I think that Yusuke and Kuwabara
could take Gon and Killua in
a fight if it came down to it.
- That's an argument we'll
have at a later date.
- That's fine. Okay.
It's gonna get too heated for
the podcast.
- It'll get too heated
and then we'll waste all of this time.
But I'm gonna put a pin in that
- We can do that.
- to fight about later.
Yeah, I think something
that anime does really well
when it's not being irritatingly horny,
which is a bone I have to pick
with the community in general
as I'm like, where are the romance animes
that aren't just like super
horny all the time, 'cause I'm-
- Don't bring the horny stick out on us.
- Look, this is from
someone who's a massive fan
of "Food Wars."
- Oh god.
- You know?
And we know this and you
mock me for it relentlessly,
and that's like totally fair.
The judges ending up naked
was always my favorite part
because like teenagers like that.
But I think what anime does really well
is representing close intimate,
communicative relationships
between male characters and young men,
which I think is
something severely lacking
in a lot of modern media.
And in like the raising and
education of specifically
cisgender males in general is like,
you're not supposed to be
emotionally close to your friends.
Like women, we got that unlocked.
That's like how we're raised
is to like be emotionally open,
and communicative, and vulnerable
with our female friends
and to be affectionate with them,
that's totally okay, and in
fact, weird if you're like
not like that, which is a
problem in and of itself
for a different conversation.
But I do like that in anime
a lot of the friendships
between men and male characters
and young boys, it is affectionate
and they're there for
each other emotionally,
and they communicate with each other,
and when they have fights and arguments
they make up with each other.
I think that that's really important
because I think a lot
of men don't have true
emotionally intimate companionship
with other men in their lives.
And I think that that's really problematic
because then their female partners
become like their emotional
outlet, and like frankly,
I ain't trying to do that kind of labor
if I'm in a relationship
with a man or a woman,
I don't wanna be their
sole emotional support.
It's exhausting. Nobody has it in them.
So I love that that's
really, really represented
like through in nakama, and
then the power of friendship
and all of that, that's a really strong
recurring theme in anime.
And most of like the male
anime stans that I know
have much healthier friendships
with their male friends
and have much better communication skills.
I think as a result of growing
up with that representation
in anime, like you have
excellent communication skills,
even when you're wrong, and... (laughs)
- Doesn't happen a lot, but okay, go on.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Okay, okay.
But like all the male weebs
that I know, generally speaking,
I said generally, 'cause I
know that there are a lot of
like anime stans that are
shitty communicators and suck
as there is in all fandoms ever.
But like you and our Annie
hoes, like Tony and Mason,
and Jacques, are all very communicative
and like very emotionally in touch
with their male friends,
and hence with like their female
friends and their partners.
And that's really wonderful.
And I don't think it can be overstated
that I do think that's a direct result
of the representation
of friendships in anime.
- I think one of the best examples
of what you're talking about right now
is in "My Hero Academia."
- Mm-hm.
- I think Deku is such
an emotional character
and it's presented, not
necessarily as a flaw,
but as something for him to overcome.
The confidence is so much
about what his journey is
and a lot of that happens
through his interactions
with his classmates.
Obviously his relationship
with Bakugo is very particular
because Bakugo is not a good friend.
Look the boy's got growth,
- But Bakugo himself is an
extremely emotional character.
They're two sides of the same coin,
which is I think why they're
set up in opposition.
Bakugo is, you know, that vaunted version
of male emotionality, which
is anger is the only emotion
you're allowed to express,
and there's no vulnerability
and he has to be tough,
and he has to be the best.
And you know, his anger is not,
well almost like dismissed,
but is accepted and almost encouraged
as like a part of his masculinity
and his like hero whatever,
and it's permissible.
It's like he has permission
to be angry and pop off,
which I think is problematic
for him and his character
development initially because, you know,
it's socially acceptable for
young men to be aggressive
especially, you know,
or training like that.
And it's violence, you're
fighting, literally, the villains.
And I think that his sort
of emotional development,
you know, when you go too far into anger,
it's like anger becomes hatred, whatever,
and hatred becomes evil.
Like he walks a very fine line
between ultimately becoming a villain
if he doesn't learn to temper that anger.
And then by that same token,
Deku in his, you know,
he's deeply emotional as well.
He cries a lot, and sure
he has his insecurity,
but ultimately he's like his
determination and his faith
in himself, and then his
friend's faith in him,
carries him through.
And I think it's very cool
that even though he's a crybaby,
and even though he gets teased for it,
he does exist in that emotional
space, and lives in it
through his friends.
And as he gains confidence
in his training, you know,
all of us have to learn to
control and manage our emotions
in healthy and productive ways.
Both of those sets of
like emotional outputs
can either be used for
good, as like motivation
to be better and to get
better and to be stronger,
or they could both potentially go down
very, very dark paths.
And I think that My Hero really,
the emotional development
of both of those kids,
and we have to remember
these are teenagerss.
- Right.
- I don't know if you remember
being a teenager, my emotions
were all over the place.
That takes years to learn how
to not only not feel ashamed
of being emotional, or being
out of control emotionally,
but also to like learn
to breathe through it
and not let those emotional outbursts
hurt the people around you.
- And I think that's one of the things
that I appreciate about how
the creator, Kohei Horikoshi,
has done Bakugo's character.
Because he could have very
easily taken Bakugo down
a dark path.
- That would have been
- I would be very easy.
- almost too predictable though.
- Yes.
- He did a wonderful job
at like, showing that development.
- Because that anger isn't
making him a villain,
it's just a part of who he is.
It's something that he has to deal with.
It's something that he has to overcome.
And I think he's started doing that,
especially where we are in the manga now,
that just because he isn't able to control
or express his emotions that well,
it doesn't make him a bad person.
Which is a really
important lesson to learn.
Like you're saying for those
years, those teenage years,
that's something that we need to hear.
- Yeah, that we all have to learn.
'cause I think that that when we as people
get really overly emotional,
no matter what emotion it is,
I think particularly young men,
but also young women
or non-binary persons,
when those feelings are so
big and so overwhelming,
there's a lot of shame
that comes along with it,
because societally speaking,
neither men nor women are supposed to have
these like really big emotional,
like you're seen as unstable,
or unhinged, or dangerous
in some way.
I think like seeing a
representation of that in media
and in anime in particular,
and then the growth
into like these feelings are okay to have,
it's all right to have big feelings,
and learning to deal with
them in a healthy way
instead of like repression and
then explosion, or you know,
wallowing to the point of toxicity,
or lashing out, either
at yourself or others,
is like super-valuable.
It's super valuable to see
that growth represented.
And I think it's very
educational in like, a weird way.
Like I myself had anger
issues for many, many years,
and I had to learn how to deal with it.
And it's hard 'cause I thought
I was sad, and it's like, no,
actually I'm really like
deeply profoundly angry
about a bunch of stuff
that's happened in my life.
And part of my therapeutic
work through that was, one,
recognizing that I was angry.
And then two, recognizing that anger,
much like joy, is a
very energetic emotion.
And if you try and push it
down, it has to come out,
it's energy, it has to come out.
And it can come out in either destructive
or productive ways, and
I think that's the lesson
that like Bakugo was learning.
He can channel that anger
into productive pursuits
once given the tools to like communicate
and understand where it's coming from
and what he could do with it,
both good and bad.
You can channel that.
So like once I figured that out,
channeled that energy into like
cleaning my house, you know,
or going to the gym or like, whatever,
and it's really useful.
Anger is a very useful emotion.
All emotions are very useful
if you utilize them appropriately.
- And kind of bringing it back to theme,
a lot of the ways that
both Deku and Bakugo learn
how to do those things is
through their relationships
with other characters
- Through opposition, mm-hm.
- Making friendships,
not just with each other,
but when you start to, what's
interesting is, you know,
you have those two kind of
factions that sort of form
around both of those characters.
Bakugo has like Kirishima and the Eijiro-
- He has the Bakusquad, and then there's
the Dekusquad.
- He's got his Bakusquad.
- Yep.
- And so in having people
see past what might be
surface level for you,
or what you project out
there and really see, okay,
you might be a crybaby or you
might be an angry asshole,
there's a lot of other stuff
that I can see behind you
and now I'm gonna ride with you.
And that bolstering, that
idea of people seeing you,
and accepting you, flaws
and all, is really powerful.
- Not only for like
the 10% that they know,
but for the 90% they don't know.
- Yep.
- For like the potential
they see in addition to the flaws
that are already present.
I mean, I feel that way about my friends,
like I've seen my friends
through like good times
and bad times, and when
they're their best selves,
and when they have not
been their best selves,
and they've seen me the same way
and they still love me, warts and all.
From rooftop to basement,
the good and the bad,
the really beautiful and the really ugly.
They love me 100% for everything I am
and for everything I will be
and everything I have been.
And I think that that's ultimately
what friendship is about.
- So along those lines, if you were to,
if you were to pick like your nakama,
like you're building your
crew, your pro-hero agency,
who are some characters
from anime that you feel
you would want by your
side for whatever reason?
Just because you love them,
because they've got skill
sets that you don't,
because that's also what it's about.
You know, friendships and
team building and stuff.
Everyone in a group of
friends isn't always the same.
You're filling gaps.
- Well, I would hope not,
exactly.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, and you want people around you
that like inspire you to
be different or you know,
that have cool stuff going on.
That's how I pick my friends anyway.
Like, people I think are really inspiring,
and really impressive,
and who I look up to
for whatever personality traits they have
that I feel I'm lacking, you know?
Okay, can I pick from like any anime ever?
- Yeah. Go for it.
- Hmm, I mean,
okay, so from "One Piece,"
just the whole crew.
I'd like to be part of my hero team.
From "Hunter X Hunter"
I'd say, Killua and Gon I really love.
I really love Bisky.
I know a lot of people
don't really love Bisky,
but I really love Bisky,
and we can talk about jewelry
and gemstones and stuff.
So I really love Bisky
from "Hunter X Hunter"
and I don't wanna hear anything about it.
I want Faye from "Cowboy Bebop."
And also Ein.
- Also Ein, nope, fair.
You need an animal.
- Yeah, I love Ein.
(Adelaide hums)
I'd want Miss Macrophage
from "Souls at Work."
She is a baller.
- No, that's a good one.
- Miss Macrophage just like
lays the hurt all the time,
and then when she isn't,
she's like la la la la la la
la la la, with all the babies.
Let's see, I'd want Hawk
from "Seven Deadly Sins"
just 'cause I like pigs.
I'd want "Sailor Moon"
to be part of my squad
as a literal goddess with
the ability to tear apart
the fabric of the universe.
I just wanna like keep my eye on her,
just want her to be around.
- So you bring up "Sailor Moon,"
which on its own, phenomenal series,
and one of the really
cool things about it is
it's such a good representation
of female friendship.
- Yeah, it really is.
I mean, like every member of that group
has their own like distinct
individual personalities
and they all get on or don't get on,
or have their like issues with each other
on a regular basis.
Like much with true friendships,
like there's sometimes when
you're just not gonna vibe
or you have arguments or you have fights,
and they're always so
communicative and fantastic
about coming back together.
And then also about like,
keeping the main goal and focus,
no matter what kind of
arguments or internal struggles
they're having, they all
show up for each other
when push comes to shove,
like when it's really
crunch time, and it's like,
I'm gotta save the universe again.
They all show up and they put it aside.
And I think through a lot
of those battles, you know,
they come out the other end
just being like, that's right,
the true friendship exists
beyond these petty disputes,
which I think is a really
good representation
of true friendship.
I mean, sure we're not like,
saving the world in real life,
but you know, it is a good reminder
that at the end of the day,
true friendship exists,
like beyond and outside all
of these like petty arguments,
or whatever that you might have.
I really like the friendship
in "Kakegurui" as well,
that sort of develops
between our lead girl,
and all the names are escaping me,
our little blonde pigtail bestie
who is such a bitch when
you first start the series,
and just watching their
friendship kind of grow.
And it's just a hilarious case
of like the black-haired girl
has the golden retriever energy,
and the blonde is like
the mean black cat energy.
And just watching those two go from being
kind of contentious
and like oil and water,
to such fast friends
that they're just like wrecking
people's shit together.
They got there through
like mutual respect,
and cooperation, and really
play on each other's like
strengths and knowledge to
ultimately succeed together.
And as they bring like other
women into their group,
and I think the representation
of female friendships
in anime, especially how
they grow and develop
is also really important in a world
where a lot of women are sort
of pitted against each other
for whatever reason.
Like seeing representation
of women working together
is really important and fabulous.
And I love "Kakegurui" as well.
- See we're using all these great examples
and I think it should be noted,
for those of you who don't know,
the creator of "Sailor Moon"
and of the creator of "Yu Yu
Hakusho" and "Hunter X Hunter"
are married in real life.
- They're married.
- That is-
- It's the coolest.
- anime and manga royalty
right there.
- That's the king and queen.
That's like the royal couple
of anime, which is so cool.
And they both just like clearly
know exactly what nakama
power of Friendship is all about.
- So you've talked about
how difficult it was
when you first moved from
Australia to the States
and really having to find your people.
Who are those nakama that
you have in your real life
right now, and how are some
ways that they've helped you
along the lines of the things
we're talking about today?
- Well, there's you, for starters.
I really appreciate our friendship,
not only because you
also like anime like me,
and not a lot of my very
close friends are into anime
and manga the way that I am.
I don't have a huge amount
of like anime manga friends
in my sort of like age group.
And I really appreciate
that you always like,
call me on my shit.
You're one of the few people I can like,
have arguments with
without it getting mean.
Like we bicker about stuff all the time.
And I really love that
about our friendship,
is that we can bicker and it's all good.
I mean, we argue about anime all the time,
and it's fantastic.
I feel like I don't have
that with a lot of people.
Like my friend Rachel is
one of my best friends,
and she, (laughs) almost
pathologically supports me
through all of my crazy phases.
And like Rachel has absolutely seen me
at my best and my worst
and still just loves me
and is ride or die.
And I think she and my friend Lizla,
sort of showed me that I am
deserving of love, and care,
and consideration, and friendship,
even when I am at my worst,
because Lizla has seen me at
my worst as well and my best.
And for those two in particular,
I want to be my best.
Like, I wanna be the best
friend I can possibly be
for both of them who have
both shown up for me,
like emotionally and physically,
and they're ride or die.
They've stuck with me
and continued to love me
through some of my most like
difficult times as an adult,
as have you.
And as far as I'm concerned,
that's worth more than
anything in the world.
It just makes me wanna be a better person
and someone that y'all can be proud of,
in addition to someone
that I can be proud of.
- I don't know how you
could have better answered
and exemplified the idea of nakama.
All right, gimme some recs.
What are you watching
right now? What's good?
- At the moment I'm
watching "Spy x Family."
I'm obsessed with "Spy x Family."
It's adorable. It's so cute.
I'm currently wearing a
"Spy x Family" t-shirt
with Bond and Anya on it.
"Kotara Lives Alone," I
highly recommend as well.
I know we've talked about
it already, but it's just,
it's a really beautiful
anime and definitely,
definitely worth a watch.
That's what I'm watching right now.
I just rewatched all of "Hunter X Hunter,"
and I rewatched like half of "Bleach,"
and then I was like, eh, bored.
Do you have any recs?
- Did you not just
jump into "Thousand-Year Blood War?"
- No.
- You should.
- Really?
- Yes.
- Should I?
Is it super gory?
- No, it's not super gory, no.
- Like gimme the pitch.
What is it?
- It's violent.
- Yeah, but everything's violent.
- Yeah, it is.
The Quincys are declaring
war on Soul Society
and they've got some
seemingly pretty valid reasons
- (gasps) Oh!
- for doing so.
- Oh!
So we're gonna get a bunch of answers
about that whole thing.
- We are, and it's
- Interesting.
- some of the most beautifully
animated, so they're
putting end of season fights
in just the middle of the series.
- Damn, okay.
- It looks beautiful.
- Interesting. All right.
- All right, all right, all right.
I need to get some more "One
Piece" under my belt as well.
I think I'm about like four seasons in,
but I have to take breaks from
it 'cause there's so much.
- Things are good right now though.
- There's so much.
- We're we're getting to the
really good parts of Wano.
A lot of the one-on-one
fights are in the midst
at the moment, especially
with my girl Nico Robin.
- I'm excited to see
more Nico Robin fights,
'cause she doesn't have a lot of fights,
like a lot of one-on-one battles.
And I feel like she uses her
Devil Fruit power so much
that we don't see her necessarily
in physical altercations
all that much.
And like as a Fish-Man Karate Master,
I wanna see more of her
stomp stomp bullshit.
Like I wanna see more of
her like float like a petal,
cut like a razor type shit.
I really love Nico so much ,
and she's such a sick character.
All right, all right, all right,
I'll put that on my to-do.
I feel like there's like so much.
Do you have any recs?
- I am catching up on
"Shaman King" right now.
I had never watched it back in the day,
but when they started remaking
it and they drop like batches
of episodes on Netflix and
I've been catching up on them
as they're coming out,
and I really dig it.
It feels like something-
- I hear really good things.
I haven't taken the time to watch it yet.
- Look, I'm a Shonen
boy through and through,
and this feels like something
that I would have loved
if I watched it when I was-
- No, you? Really?
- Yeah.
- A Shonen boy? Stop.
- I'm watching "Shaman
King," "My Hero Academia,"
"Bleach," "Chainsaw Man,"
"One Piece," "Spy Family,"
season three of "Mob Psycho 100."
- There's just so many things to watch
and so little time.
- We're eating good.
- Yeah.
- There's so much.
- You know what I really loved,
a manga that I really, really
loved, that I read recently,
that made me cry buckets?
"A Man and His Cat."
- I haven't read it.
- Oh, I have the first five volumes.
- Also, you still have my
"Flying Witch" volumes.
- Yes, and I told you, I was
like, "I need to return these."
And you were like, "No,
those aren't mine."
I was like, "Yes they are."
I still have like three of them,
so I'll bring them by next week.
- I would never say that.
"Flying Witch" is the greatest
Slice of Life series ever created.
- It's beautiful. It's so cute.
- Also people, if you haven't read
or watched "Flying Witch," do it.
Well, Addie, those were a lot
of really good recommendations.
You've, always been great at
giving me new things to watch,
like "BOFURI," I always
say when I'm into that,
it came from you.
- It's so cute.
- It's very wholesome.
And as someone who's over the
isekai genre a little bit,
it was a nice injection
of something different.
- Thanks, man.
- It was a pleasure having you on.
This was a lot of fun.
Thank you for joining me.
- Nah, thank you for
having me. It's been great.
I haven't gotten to sort
of chop it up about anime
in a hot minute, so I
appreciate it, thanks.
Thanks for having me on.
And for those of you who leave comments
in the comments section, I don't,
I'm not gonna fight with you
about the animes that I like.
Just live with it.
- I will fight with you.
(Adelaide laughs)
I absolutely will.
Especially if it's about "Hunter X Hunter"
versus "Yu Yu Hakusho," I am
prepared at any point in time.
- (laughs) Ready to
throw hands at any point.
- Well, thank you everyone for listening
to the "MANA Podcast," and a
big thanks to my own nakama,
Adelaide Kane, for joining
me on this episode.
- Aw, thank you so much for having me.
- You can catch Addie
on literally everything.
She's always working.
(Adelaide laughs)
She does so much great stuff
right now on "Grey's Anatomy"
and you can follow them on
Instagram at @AdelaideKane.
And so if you've enjoyed this episode,
please don't forget to
subscribe to our podcast
on your favorite app.
Please leave a rating and a
review, hopefully positive,
I'm very sensitive.
I'm Matt Owens. Thanks for listening.
(bright music)